hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the vhs olympiads 2022 it is uh
pragernanda versus avasiv
india two faces uh uh azerbaijan and uh
it is one of the two big clashes that
are happening in round nine so india two
faces azerbaijan uh and of course uh the
youngsters of team uzbekistan uh face
armenia uh so we're gonna discuss about
what happened in that match but first to
get um some things out of the way uh i
know you guys are wondering about
bookish how did he play as he faced
chocolate and mommy he had the white
pieces it was a very very quick draw and
there was not really much happening
there bookish i felt was in absolute
control for the entire game uh in the
end he could not pursue that nine out of
nine but i mean it would be uh silly to
to try and push something against the
mummy the r1 on board one uh so uh his
incredible run comes to an end but even
with a draw against mohamed er he still
gains rating points so we're going to
discuss the the ratings in um
in the second video uh so that's what
happened on board one on board two we
also had a draw uh between um
and uh
uh and on board four india 2 suffered a
loss ramak sadwani uh lost his game uh
to to absorb and now it is up to paragon
uh to level the score otherwise india
will lose to azerbaijan
so let's see what happened in this game
prague has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 with knight to f6 c4 e6 knight
to f3 and b6 here uh durability goes for
the queen's indian defense and we've
discussed this quite a lot ever since
alpha zero said that uh quincy indian
defense is completely
unplayable yeah humans haven't really
played it all that much but we still see
it from time to time uh with some uh new
new uh ideas uh so uh let's let's see
how prague goes about this with g3 now
this is all uh top standard theory so
nothing new here bishop to a6 uh with b3
defending the c4 pawn and the bishop to
b4 check we have bishop to d2 capture
sunday two queen characters and now uh
we have ponta c6 uh bishop the g2 very
nicely uh developed uh as the the rook
on e8 might be hanging in some lines and
here just d5
we have castles and now knight b to d7
rook to c1 and now uh here we have
castles by deuteronomy and again this is
all being played before a4 by problem
and now comes bishop the b7 bishop to b7
is the first real rare move of the game
usually people just go queen b7 hero
rook to c8 but the v7 is incredibly rare
and now uh
uh
prague goes knight to c3
uh and it is now as of 12 that we have a
completely new game there is a game
where a5 was attempted the valentina
goon in the played it against anastasia
mandarin the russian championship of
2017 for women in
saint petersburg uh but here of course
we have knight to c3 and uh now it's a
completely new game so rook to b8 uh now
it's new territory the order of uh
gets the rook over to the b file uh like
we said the bishop controlling this
diagonal you do not want your bishop
there and if a5 is played or something
like that you might have problems also
if the bishop moves a b5 is is an option
so c5 is an option
uh
the rook is better placed on b8 so here
we have knight to e1 and now pawn to c5
opening up the position c contrast on b5
c captures on d4 and now queen captures
on b4 and not knight to c5 of course now
you cannot go for any captures as the
queen on on d4 would hang so rook beat
the e1 i rotate the b1 uh and now e
captures on the e5 uh the valley just
wins back his spawn so knight to f3 and
now knight to e6 chasing away progress
queen with queen back to b1 and now
knights the e4 offering the queen trade
and while probably could go for this
it doesn't give him all that much for
example you trade knight capture spawn
characters queen capture 78 rupee
captures and now you can go knight and
knight to e5 you can try and um get this
the rook the c7 if the knight ever moves
but with the knight on e6 it's not a
really uh scary position for black so
probably keeps all of the material on
the board he goes knight to b5 uh now
controls the c7 square with the knight
as well so now queen to f6 and now rook
to c2 and here uh it seems like maybe
you can kick away the knight play a6
kick with the knight and get the knight
to c3 to win some material the problem
is if you play a6 knight comes to b4 the
queen no longer guards the c3 square so
that's why
it is not a viable option so here just a
five by during violet and now point the
e3
uh also the rook and c2 is doing a fine
job guarding the f2 pawn so if the
knight on f3 removes you don't have to
worry about queen captures on f2 so
rugby to see it and now rook beat the c1
probably doubles up on the c file knight
six to c5 uh closing the c file and now
knight f to d4 and you can see that the
progress pieces are now excellently
placed the the rooks controlling the c
file the vishwan g2 uh but the violence
piece is also doing incredible work the
knights here very very strong the queen
here very active and uh well with the
bishop for the moment uh hitting his own
form uh but that's uh
that's uh you know usually the fate of
the light square bishop when you're
playing the the black pieces it takes a
while for it to come alive so g6 and now
queen to f3 uh progress is all right uh
the only way to continue is to trade
queens and uh it seems that you're
rightly agrees with probably s he
declines the trade he goes back queen to
a7 bishop to f1 now at end knights the
g5 kicking away the queen queen to b1
and now queen back to f6 we have queen
back to g4 and now knight g to e4 that
we have queen to f4 again offering a
queen trade and again adult violet
declines this he prefers his chances
with queens on the board and here prague
says all right now it's my time to
attack and displace ponte h4 now uh h5
is coming maybe even h6 as black is
without dark square bishop so this would
uh
uh well this would uh uh make it very
very hard for for for you to play with
black so the shop the a6 and now comes
ponte h5 with bishop characters on b5 uh
here dora valley decided that the bishop
here was not all that impressive and
that is better to just trade it away for
one of the very strong knights a
captures on b5 and now rook c the e8 uh
we have rook to d1 uh still waiting with
any any pawn pushes here you you could
put the pawn all the way to h6 but then
black would probably consolidate with
something like f6 or f5 king to h8 and
his position would be okay so you have
to wait with moves like this so rook to
d1 and now queen to b7 and bishop to g2
and now on to f5 uh very very nicely
done uh queen to f3 and now uh
defending that h5 phone but now just on
the g5 and here uh things start to get
really out of control here now point is
if you try something like h6 maybe you
want to bring the queen over to h5 uh we
could even see a draw by repetition for
example rook f6 goes after the pawn
queen defends the pawn rook to g6 now
you can bring the queen back to f3 and
now we might see a repetition rook f6
queen h5 and so on uh because the uh the
f5 pawn is hanging and uh if you if you
move this rook over to f8 the defendant
then you no longer control the e5 square
maybe the knight comes to c6 then to e5
and then it could be could be
anything so instead we have rook to b2
probably prepares b4 if he can do this
he's going to open up the the a file and
now king to h8 the king will be much
safer on this diagonal uh b4 by prague
and now a captures on b4 rogue captures
and now knight the c3 attacking the rook
on d1 rook to d2 and now knight three to
e4 here maybe there was a way to
make an improvement here the knight will
come to the sorry the knight will come
to e4 at some point but the rook to a8
might be a nice inclusion before that
but okay knight three to e4 attack the
rook rook to d1 and not knight to c3
here dora valley repeats once rook to d2
knight five to e for now bringing the
other knight closer and now rook to c2
putting pressure on the knight and now
it's a little bit different now of
course you can play rook to a8 which
happens in the game but now rook b3 and
now you're just threatening to give up a
rook for the two knights so rook to a1
with check
not king to h2 if you go king to h2 then
it's game over then just g4 and you
don't have a way of defending your h5
pawn queen has to move now comes queen
to e8 incredible move uh not not even
queen to f7 then you can play queen to
h6 after queen to e8 now it's a game
over because now uh if you if you try
this queen to h6 move there's rook f6
and now the queen has to go back and
then queen captures on h5 just wins the
game so after rook to a1 check bishop to
f1 uh pragananda goes um
for the absolute strongest move and now
knights the a4 preparing to shift the
knight back to c5
uh rook to d3 and now rook to e1 and
this move is maybe a bit of a time
waster maybe night uh night coming to c5
is the is the quicker way to go but uh
uh this game is so complicated it's hard
to really say what is what rook d1 was
played and now rook to a3 now prague
goes uh for the doubling of the rooks
and the a file knight eight the c5 and
the rook c the a2 now preparing to bring
the uh to bring the rooks into the game
with rook to a7 maybe even rook to a8 so
f4 durability continues his attack and
now e captures on f4 we have g4 finally
chasing away the queen now the h flat
one becomes weak queen the h1 here the
uh h51 is still being defended and maybe
prague can even shift the queen into the
attack via the h4 square if the knight
moves maybe between g5 maybe you can
gain access to some of these squares so
knight the e6 offering a trade of
knights and here probably goes for it
rook to a8
uh we have knight captures on d4 and
before capturing a d4 you have we have
to uh decide that this is the best
course of action for black because the
knight guards the rook and f8 but if you
don't play this you don't really have a
move so just to give you an example if
you try something like king j now you're
defending the rook knight characters on
d4 becomes an idea uh prague can just
trade rook characters king captures go
knight to c6 and here with the rook
having access to eight and queen having
access access to h4 uh its game over
black will just get checkmated
regardless of what you play let's say
knight seven you stop the rook queen to
h for now and there is nothing you can
do here if d4 you start pushing your
pass pawn uh just rookie two you offer a
rook trade and once black uh does this
uh black is really without moves point
being if you play something like d3 we
can even capture this and if queen
captures just queen e7 check king the g8
is now h6 and now you are getting
checkmated if queen d1 let's say you try
something like queen a1 to stop
checkmate then comes knight to e5 and
now there is no defense against both
queen f7 and uh now as the knight is
blocking g7 queen to g7 so that that
being the idea so knight capture 74 is
the only move black has durability plays
it now comes rook captures an f8 and now
came to g7 attacks progress rook and now
rook f back to a here rook the b8 is the
engine's favorite but it's such a weird
move to play going after a pawn in uh in
a you know a crazy situation like this
so rook after a it probably goes for the
more human move uh and now comes the
knight to f3 with check and this seems
like a really good move uh but it's
actually a move that again it gets
durable into a losing position here of
course you see that the rooks are coming
to a7 so you have to play king to h6 but
i mean a crazy position knight f3 check
king to g2 now comes king h6 but now it
is much too late uh but prague does not
find the the correct way he plays rook
to c2 uh the correct way is actually to
play rook to a7 it seems like a simple
move to
miss but the point is after you play
queen the e6 because you have to keep an
eye on the b6 pawn and also you kind of
have to keep an eye on the h7 pawn but
now for example rook h8 goes after the
pawn here you will defend the queen f5
hoping to give up the queen for two
rooks but of course white is not forced
to capture rook v8 goes after the pawn
and once you defend it again now you're
gonna play rook to b7 and now you are
attacking this one and this one and uh
black for of course cannot defend both
of them if you try knight to f6 just
bishop to d3 and that's it look at this
rook captures on an h1 rook captures an
h7 with check knight captures and rogue
captures here with checkmate so that's
kind of the point uh so easy easy to
miss uh so here rook the c2 was played
prague wants to go for rooks that rook
to c6 and now comes a queen to e7 here
you should really close the
position with knight to c5 but i believe
this is what prague had in mind and he
calculated it well his idea was that he
gives up the exchange here uh he plays
rook a6 check king goes here h6 check
king moves and now b6 and now with queen
having access to h5 and the past pawn
here he has excellent winning chances so
instead okay rook c2 queen the e7 by
doer violet now comes rook to c6 with
check knight to f6 and now rook to a3
here prague has ideas of even capturing
an f3 but the main idea is going for
rook to e3 especially if the rook on e1
moves
and now what do you play uh well uh it's
uh very very hard to make a move here
the rook is hanging but then you allow
rook captures on f6 so here uh prague is
uh deciding to give back the exchange
and that there isn't anything better
that you can play so there are by the
captures here prague characters on f6
king to g7 and now rook captures on v6
the only way to continue playing this
but now h6 without the white being able
to push h6
it's very very hard to get this queen
into the game so here prague goes for a
nice little move rook to g6 check and
incredible as it is here dora valley
makes a critical critical error here he
has to play king to f7 and of course it
makes sense because you know
what is coming uh but he played king to
h7 point is that after king to f7 uh you
can simply play rook captures on g4 and
there is no good move white can make
next move is knight to d2 and uh you
will
uh you're just lost you're you're losing
the bishop there's no way to play this
however after king the h7 uh there is a
way to play this rook captures on g4 was
played and now the problem is that
knight to d4 is no longer a knight that
it is no longer an option because now
the king is on a light square blush of
d3 check and we pick up the rook on e1
so yeah you can play that so here d4 and
our ball starts pushing this pass pawn
now comes rook the g6 the only winning
move for problem uh and the point being
now that um if knight to d2 you can just
play king to h3 and after rook captures
an f1 you just checkmate the black king
that's the point uh the knight that
leaves you no longer works kings h8 and
now queen g7 will be checkmate so
instead after rook to g6 queen that e7
was played by dorado bali but now the
opposition is still winning for prague
he has a beautiful winning move so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for prague while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh always
looking for incredible ways to sacrifice
your queen and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
the d3 uh we can do it in even slower
slow motion because this is quite quite
the move uh and basically it it looks
fancy but it's a queen trade so
congratulations to everyone who spotted
it uh there is no defense here for black
point is if you capture the queen now we
just play rook to e6 check we pick up
the black queen and of course the
position is completely winning king g7
rogue captures here with checking f8
rook c7 and it's a very simple win for y
b6 b7 b8 as the bishop covers b1 so the
rule cannot go behind the pass pawn so
instead we've cleaned the a3 here uh not
saying okay you uh open up a discovery
i'm just gonna capture your bishop uh
but that also means that uh prague will
win the rook on e1 so here rook to e6
with check queen captures on d3
eliminating the checker and now rook
captures an e1 knight captures an e1 and
now queen captures an e1 uh leaving
prague up many many pawns so here are
queen captures on b5 but now queenie for
checked king to g8 and duncan's queen to
g6 and he was in this position on move
66 that was durability resigned the game
and pragananda is the hero of round nine
as he saves the day for india too uh as
like we said uh assadvani lost on on
board four and now the uh the the match
is equalized by progress great victory
over durability here you resign because
all of the pawns will now fall for
example queen captures on h6 now you'll
get some check to pick up this pawn at
some point or even if k8 you can even go
win g6 check and i have king d8 you can
even play queen g5 check and force a
queen trade it's incredibly simple to
win this so of course that's why uh the
valley resigned the white king is close
enough to stop the pawn here so you
don't have to worry about that
uh so yeah after uh queen to g6 or
violet resigned and a very very
important victory for uh
uh for prageranda
now what does this mean for the actual
standings of the olympia we're gonna
discuss this after the second video that
i make as uh the second important match
was armenia facing uzbekistan and uh
well let's just say armenia did not have
the greatest of times
so that's the game i hope you guys uh
hope you hope you guys enjoyed it was a
really wild one uh many chances for both
sides but indian uh prague prevails uh i
would like to thank braxton reynolds uh
david kimura uh
who will be in joshua hadley for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad until it finishes uh so thank
you i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day